Speaker 1: A 16 year old pregnant girl in Florida
will not be able to get an abortion because a
court has decided that she is not sufficiently
mature enough to decide for herself whether it's
the right decision to carry the fetus to term
or to get an abortion. This is absolute madness.
The girl's name is not being provided as she is
under 18, and they want to protect her identity.
But Florida has a new 15 week abortion ban, the
constitutionality of which is being questioned.
But it's staying in place for now, at least.
The state brought that threshold down from the
24 weeks back, a couple of months ago. And there
is a state law in Florida that requires minors
to get parental consent for an abortion, which
I would argue should not be necessary, because
even though you're a minor, it's still your body
after all. It's still going to be a decision that
involves you for the next 18 years plus. So it
seems like they only had this rule in place as
a way to embarrass the girl who becomes pregnant,
to have to have her go to her parents and explain
the situation that she's in and try to get their
approval. But as it pertains to this story,
the girl in question could not get her parental
consent because she is parentless and she lives
with a relative and has an appointed guardian.
But that wasn't good enough for a circuit court
judge who denied the parental consent waiver and a
three judge panel upheld the decision. A statement
from the appeals court said the appellants had not
established by clear and convincing evidence that
she was sufficiently mature to decide whether
to terminate her pregnancy. So per the state
of Florida, the girl is not mature enough to
decide whether an abortion makes sense for her,
yet she is somehow mature enough to carry a baby
to term, give birth and raise it to adulthood.
How does that make any sense at all? Something
tells me that being a parent requires a lot more
maturity than deciding whether a medical procedure
for someone in your position makes sense for you.
So this is just the latest example of Republican
barbarity on the topic, like in the lead up to
Roe versus Wade getting overturned when we could
kind of see the writing on the wall because of
Trump's Supreme Court justices. And then when
the draft opinion was leaked and then when it
was made official back in June, all along the
right wing assured the rest of the country that
they were going to be responsible on this abortion
issue. If Roe got overturned, that they would not
be completely draconian in how they addressed
the matter. And they would say things like,
oh, well, we'll have exceptions for rape. Well,
now that's being put into question because they
realized how logistically challenging that would
be, because it could easily lead to an increase in
false rape accusations. Then they'd say things
like, Oh, well, there'll be exceptions for
life of the mother. When the life of the mother
is put at risk, you'll be able to get an abortion
in that instance. But now they're realizing that
you can't always assess risk levels in this way,
where it's like 100% that the mother is going
to survive if she has the child, or 100%
chance that she's going to die if she has the
child, like usually it's in this gray area where
you don't know with any certainty what's going
to happen. So who's going to decide whether or
not you fit under that exception for Life of
the Mother? And they also used to say, Oh,
well, if Roe versus Wade gets overturned, then
you're going to be able to travel to a different
state to get an abortion if it's illegal in your
state. Now we're starting to see states try to
criminalize that very practice as well. So the
reality has been a lot more draconian than many
of us could have even imagined. And if there's
any silver lining at all in the horrors that
these countless women have had to deal with
across the country, including in this story,
it's that maybe it will incentivize
people to go out and vote in the fall.
Maybe Democrats will be able to ultimately hold on
to the House of Representatives. Maybe they'll be
able to pick up a couple of seats in the Senate so
that we can move to eliminate the filibuster and
work to codify Roe versus Wade into law.
That has to be the path forward because
we absolutely cannot trust Republicans with
control over this abortion issue. And sadly,
we're probably going to see plenty more cases like
this one out of Florida. It's absolutely sickening